All right, we're ready to go. Welcome to another zoom call for some reason. Zoom is
There we go. I don't know what happened in a different way. All right, now I can see your chat
So feel free to chat in questions. If you have them, let's get started and just a reminder to go
to the homepage of the member site to look for an outspinse
Like I had to cancel a zoom a couple weeks ago or something like that
So you'll know it is in there and you're a minor to self-schedule your appointments
When you have need to do so
Okay, so let's talk about this. First one. Please give me the dosage for one bottle of ParaClear
You recommended I take I weigh 99 pounds
Okay, so the pros and cons of ParaClear so ParaClear is
our private labeled
nutritional, herbal, anti-paracidic
Anti-bacterial can be an antifungal can be an antiviral
The reason why I like it so much is that it has so many different urbels in there that are
Dolde anti-paracidic, anti-fungal, anti-bacterial, anti-miral
The reason why I
I
Say it's a negative is because it has so many and it's a low dosage of each one of those things
So you know, let's say you make a capsule and it's just vitamin C and no filler whatsoever, you know, you could get you know
several thousand milligrams of vitamin C in it if you make a capsule and you have
15 different ingredients where you can only get one 15th of everything in that capsule
So you have to take more capsules really to get to the
dosage to be a
you know a
Healthy dose to kill a parasite
So that being said ParaClear has a lot in there so it's it's killing parasites and
other pathogens through multiple different metabolic pathways
The negative again is that chips take a lot of them so but the positive is
Whether you're dealing with parasites or pathogens, you're typically are not taking it on a daily basis
It's not like something you're gonna stay on the rest of your life
You may go through a half a bottle of it. You may go through a one bottle of ParaClear and
That's all you're gonna take so you have to take a fairly healthy dose
Um, so given 99 pounds how many should you take?
Well, you're no the amount you should take is not totally just based upon weight. It's based upon
Tolerance nutritional and supplemental tolerance also on the bottle
It's comes in a bottle ParaClear comes in a bottle of 180 capsules
Because it's mid you know your ex take a lot of many multiple capsules
Other bottle I think it says serving size is three capsules, but if somebody was
200 pounds they may have to take you know 12 to 15 of them a day
Maybe they're only gonna take six a day. It depends on what you're dealing with
So if you're dealing with a possible I love ParaClear for
H. Pylora infection, which is a bacteria, but it's got a lot of stuff in there that is good for H. Pylora
But you have to take it with your 90 day pounds you have to take at least still have to take at least six a day
And you would maybe only do six a day for a week and then you might drop off completely and see how you feel
See how that might change your symptoms. So
Yeah, like for instance I take ParaClear, but I might only take it like three or four days out of the month
And then I don't take it for a while
Or I might take it a day and I take six or eight of them and then I don't take it for another week
And then I take six or eight or nine of them and then I don't take it for another week
So that's how I take it just because everybody has parasites
Everybody has pathogens and it's a good thing to help just
Balance your gut, but if you know you're dealing with an active parasite or active pathogen
If I feel like H. Pylora is rising up at me then I'll then I would take it for a longer period of time
But at 90 a.m. I'd still say you take three to six a day
Peds in how active your you know, whatever you're dealing with is and then
You know, then drop it down and then you can pulse it
So maybe then you'd only take it three days a week and then you feel like you're getting better completely
And you feel like you're over that then you maybe stop completely and you put it in your comfort and you use it as net as needed
So typically anti-paracidic things like this you're not going to take
continuously on a daily basis
I guess I guess this is something you could take on a daily basis if you just took water two of them
But it's going to have less effect
Then you know take it a high dose of try to kill something that's there
Well, that answers your question. I just got an email that
Advertised this DNA test that's supposed to tell you about your metabolism
likelihood of being bothered by different toxins all to help you eat the right diet etc
Is this the same information in the DNA testing that you did for us?
Just not spelled out as much and could we get the same information if we dug in that further?
Um, so there's a number of DNA tests on the market that will just test certain genes
There's companies that will say
Do this do our diet DNA testing and charge a couple hundred dollars for a diet DNA testing and they give you a printed
Readout and they're really testing maybe four or five families of genes maybe a total of 30 40 genes
Steps that they're testing and then they're making recommendations based upon that
um
Is that okay to do that? I think it's okay to do that as a practitioner. It's okay to do that as a company
I just don't think it's a very good value
Because it's all you know our tests for basically all the known steps that are available for anybody to test these days
Which I mean, you know, you're not going to get a
You know, you're not going to get 30 40 steps. You're going to get you know
Uh, you know
I don't know how many are things test for know probably about 90 000 steps
So I don't think that your
Uh, as far as value goes plus I think that some of these read into it
In ways that you shouldn't really read into it for instance
So if we look at your HLA genes so your HLA genes
Our genes that can signify that a person could be sensitive to gluten
Oh
Does have a double elial defects on your HLA genes mean that you have a gluten sensitivity
No, it doesn't it means that you have um
You
Have
Genes that indicate that you could become a gluten sensitive
But it doesn't mean you have gluten sensitivity
Just like there's genes for
Peanut sensitivity and mold sensitivity
Does that mean that you are going to be sensitive to mold and peanuts?
No, it doesn't
Um, that's why you know, you might get mad at me when I give you a vague answer on the genetics where it says
Oh, can I drink coffee or not? Well
Just because I have the genes that would suggest that I don't detoxify caffeine very well
Doesn't mean that I don't
So
same thing with
Uh, then you could be bothered by different toxins. Okay, so if I have a lot of gene defects on my pond one pathway
That means hey, I might want to support that pathway and you know what toxins are detoxified on the pond one pathway
Well pesticides and herbicides, so I probably should stay away from pesticides and herbicides
Well to truth is you should stay away from pesticides and herbicides even if you don't him
Detox pathway defects, but should you support it especially if you're dealing with a serious disease like cancer?
Yes, that's why we do make
nutritional recommendations off your genetics
But they're just recommendations and it doesn't mean you necessarily have to stay on that the rest of your life
nor does it mean that
As far as from a from a food standpoint
Nor does it mean that you're going to have that you actually do have antibodies to that food
This is your genes
So your genes are hard and fast. That's what it is now your genes can get worse. You could have more defects if you're exposed to more toxins
But you're not going to ever get better and just because I have a lot of defects. Let's say let's have defects done by HLA pathways
Um, and so that I go, oh, maybe I do want to not eat so much gluten. Well, there's not lots of other reasons why you wouldn't want to eat gluten
Um, but so this maybe that's not the best example. Let's say the defects on the gene pathway for mold
and peanuts
Does that mean I don't want to eat peanuts because I'm going to have a sensitivity to that
No, it doesn't should I you know, should I take note of that and should I be aware of that and and take note if I do have a mold sensitivity or
That I am I have issues when I eat peanuts. Yeah, I mean of course I should be aware of that. It's good to know these things
But it doesn't mean just because I have a defector that that that is going to
equate to
A certain ill health and that's the only thing I don't like about a lot of the gene
Uh, test out there
Uh, there's and I mentioned before there's Facebook pages about difference
There's there's literally an MTHFR Facebook page
And I belong to it just to kind of get an idea of what people are talking about
To be honest, it's absolutely absurd
You talk about being angry at the medical profession for not
caring for their patients correctly
Well, honestly, I get even more perturbed at the alternative um functional medicine
alternative doctor um sites that make these claims like oh if I have an MTHFR defect, I am
I don't detox. I don't this and this is the cause of all by ill health and this is like it's just literally absurd
um, so
You just have to be careful of all that
Okay, I think it's a great idea for anybody to get their genetics done so you can say
Well, this would be really good to be careful with this be careful with this and watch this and watch this
Though those things you should be watching it being careful of anyhow
But sometimes would you see something in black and white it motivates you to understand that that could be a possibility
For instance the gene for um
For uh lactose intolerance
If I don't have those defects, I have a chance of being lactose intolerant
Well, maybe that's an issue that with your digestive system that you should get tested and
Maybe that will indicate
Maybe I just stay away from dairy for a while and see if that calms it down. No, it doesn't well
Maybe I should get a test done and do an antibody test so it can give you indications for other things
Um, but it doesn't mean because you have the broccogene defect that you're going to get breast cancer
Nor does it mean that you have a pond one gene defects that you can't detox at all
Um, or does it mean it you can't equate those things really
It's more important to understand epigenetics, which means what your environment does with the genes that you have
So just because I'm Irish doesn't mean I'm going to be an alcoholic, but you know
Genetically, maybe because I'm Irish
That I'm saying it's because I am Irish maybe I shouldn't be careful about that
Maybe if I look at my family tree and there's a you know, just about everybody who is in the alcoholic
I should be careful about that. It's wise to look at genetics. It's wise to look at
Your ancestry. It's wise to look at things to help govern behavior if you don't want to walk down that same pathway
Um, but it isn't a
Like a you know, you're not saying it's still that this is now who you are
This is what you're going to become because of your genetics and a lot of companies
Kind of sell their products that way and I would be careful of that
I mean, I could easily said you know give put together a
Protocol based upon your genetics and say well you have this so you are definitely, you know
This is your problem. This is going to be your problem for life
And you don't have any choice in the matter and you can't do anything about it
Um, you have to be able to sell more stuff that way, but it's dishonest
Um, it's I think it's not any less dishonest than
Then some of the things that oncologists are doing and medical field is doing so I you know
We have to be honest in our assessment of things too. So
Long answer for do I think it's valuable to do this
I do not think so no um, I think it could
You could influence you in the wrong way too. So
Sorry next question
Do you recommend fasting for a breast cancer patient who is in a revision or let's just say for any cancer patient who's in very mission
If so for how long uh and how often
Also do you recommend 3D sonograms to check or
To check for uh cancer as opposed to mammograms
Um second question first definitely sonograms are much less invasive than a mammogram, which is radiation
I'm not
Positive about all the technology that's involved with the 3D sonograms, but it's still sound waves not
X-rays
So X-rays
Mammograms done on that regular of a basis. I know sometimes there may be an indication to do one
Um, but to do regular mammograms
Annual mammograms that's a lot of radiation over time and I don't think that's good for
Your cells because that's what damages cells and radiation is one of the key things that could cause cancer. So no, I'm not a fan of that
The first question do you recommend fasting for a cancer patient who's in remission or a cancer patient who's not in remission?
The only thing I'd say about
We'll say no to someone who's not in remission is if you you know, you're at an an end job too much weight loss
We don't want to fast and send somebody into a cacacic state
Um, but somebody who is not in that state or is in remission
Um, there's
Fasting can be very good. So we talk a lot about intermittent fasting or time restricted eating
We have multiple blog posts of that so I'd refer you to our website to get a look at the blog post on that
Can a person fast
Yes, there is some
Studies that are out there that show that you have an increase in IGF1 if you fast more than 24 hours
Um, so we have kind of always tended to
Unless you feel really spiritually led to fast more than 24 hours
We say keep your fast at 24 hours or less so fasting a day a week
It was very often biblical practice to fast a day a week
Um, what does that make you more spiritual? No, but it's that maybe there can be some cleansing health benefits to doing something like that
Um, so uh, yeah, so I typically recommend, you know, 24 hour fast
Um, maximum that I've had don't understand I've had patients that have fasted for three days
I've had patients that done 10 15 day fasts. I had a patient years ago that did a 40 day fast
Now they look pretty
Sparse after that 40 day fast. I'm not sure how healthy that was for them
But they did they had other reasons for doing it
So it's you know, I don't think there's anything. I think there's much benefit to fasting. There is there is um
Just tons of data and
Out there and research on fasting
But you can get some of the same benefits doing a um, you know, a modified fast um and uh
So look at the look at the information that's out there on our website about that
But there's certainly I don't think any downsides to doing a fast
Any other questions?
What do I think about the whole body MRIs
Um, that do not use cloud trash. I think you're talking about the pronovo
Uh system. So the pronovo system that's what I had done
The last thing I had done was the pronovo scan
Um, I think they're great. So I think there's huge benefit to them
Um, you know, there's the MRIs without con there's no contrast to use the MRIs without contrast are
You know considered fairly not invasive. Now there's some alternative practitioners say well
You're still dealing with a very high magnetic field that can mess up your electrical system and such but
certainly the um
They um uh
Uh are less invasive than radiation
So it was from the Simon bed. It only cost $600 per dollar. So I don't think it was the pronovo
I could email you one of the articles. Yeah, I don't know. There may be some other systems that are coming out of the market
So my last one I did was
About three years ago or something like that
so um
Yeah, um
They could be a good indication like any test, you know, no test is perfect
So you could say oh, I did a pet scan and it was all
clean so I don't have to you know
You don't do anything anymore um and you know
It could not be picking up something that um it's just too small for it to pick up
Or you could you do a pet scan and it shows a hotspot and it's
And it's uh
You know a pseudo tumor where it's a pseudo enlargement that is
That is not correct. So no test is is perfect. So
If you just keep that in mind and you go okay, well, I get it. I'm gonna do
You know trying to do things as less invasive as possible
Then that's a good thing to do. I do think so that you know if you do something you have to plan on
Okay, if if I get a use this to monitor my
You know cancer or lack thereof um, then you keep doing the same test from the same place
Um, that's always beneficial
Whether even if you do a CT scan or a pet scan, it's always best to go back to the same place if possible
Because you're gonna have a greater degree of accuracy to measure apples to apples
um, and do comparisons
so um
You know, I'm not sure of the system that you're talking about and how accurate it is to see
um
Uh, different cancers if it's the Pradovo
At least they counted the information that's out there
Uh, the studies that they they refer to that it's
As accurate as a pet scan
um, with no invasiveness so
Uh, so it gives you the contrast or it's not just giving you hotspots like a pet scan. It's giving you
visual
um, acuity of different organs and tissues
so
I think there's benefits to that. So I'm not sure about the exact machine you're talking about but
um
If they if they show confidence is in their studies about
Uh, cancer and what size that they can measure cancer as to go forward with for that price
It can be very beneficial
Now a lot of some of those alternative things are not covered by insurance so
Oh, but it's $650 that might be your gold payment on a regular pet scan
And then a pet scan is obviously ready even since you don't want to be doing that too often
Well, okay any other questions my ecologist
Said he was aware of them but still not sure
But they are usually at least 10 years behind, right
Well, I'd say they are usually
Behind and less it's a piece of equipment that they can cover by insurance and they have it in their office at all
And it's the best thing in the world
So
That's just the way it is
opinion on
Cryo surgery for deboking
So we've had patients with
Breast cancer that did cryo surgery
A cryo surgery bestitis
Um, and I gladly share the doctor who did that except he retired
Um, so they're not in business anymore because he was he was just kind of at a cutting edge in his later years and he's
Retired and
Practicing anymore, but yeah, I think you know, there's this that person was very happy with their surgery
um, so
um, but quite honestly there's you know if you go to a skilled surgeon no matter how they do the surgery
I think that
That you could be happy with the surgery
So partly, you know, just so much depends on the skill of the surgeon
Um, so that's where I always say if you're going to do a lumpectomy or mastectomy or any surgery
You have to be really comfortable with the person that's doing it you feel like
They're not just an ego maniac, but they really are skilled surgeon who really cares about their patients
And if you feel good about that then that's important
If you don't feel good about that to just get second opinions because it's it's important to
For you to feel confident in it
Yeah, searching for options. Yes
A cancer markers are
CA 15 3 19
Uh 27 29 21.6 and
CA 125 is 5.6 should I feel good about these results
Well, if your tumor markers are within normal range, you should feel good about those results
um, but it partly depends on
If you if this is the first time you've ever had them done
Because not to burst anybody's bubble, but
If you've never ran tumor markers ever before
And now you're just ready them for the first time in there within normal range
We don't know
Yeah, you know how good of a news that is it's always good news when any labs come back normal
But we don't know how good news it is if this is the first time they were ever run
Um, that's why we've always encouraged getting tumor markers done as soon as possible because
You want to get a baseline of where you're at
So
So if in the past your tumor markers were elevated
Whether this is this is time to celebrate so anytime you have
Um abnormal labs that come back normal after
You know a series of you know treatments
You know, that's how you could objectively measure the efficacy of the care
So um, that would be really good news
If you oh, I'd never ran these before these are well in truth they they could have been much higher
And an odour range
elevated
In the past or some people
With cancer don't show elevated tumor markers. So um
Uh
That's I mean typically with breast cancer you're gonna have elevated tumor markers more often than not
Um, many other cancers don't show elevated tumor markers
But typically with cancer you would uh with breast cancer you would
But you always wanted that's why I look at that plant work
Why I always recommend getting regular plant work because you look at it
You know how it changes over time
Um, and that's that's really the most important marker, you know
If oh my gosh, I have anemia. Well
What was it two months ago? Oh
Here it is. Oh, it was way worse two months ago. Okay. We're going in the right direction. You're looking at trends
Um, or it was it wasn't this I didn't have anyemia two months ago. Okay. This is more trendy than the wrong direction. We got to figure out why
so um
We do want to look at past markers. All right, we will
Say goodbye. I think um, we don't have any other questions
Thanks for everybody being on and we will
Talk again next week. All right